[Music]  bikini car wash [ __ ] Mick shoot crap  after planning the wedding planning the  century cosmetic industry  shut up huh I've been this excited since  she became a publicly kettering what you  it would be she's got it she's good I'm  gonna do it a minute  [Music]  [Laughter]  [Music]  remember what you said to me back when I  didn't resort Sara I don't even know  what that means  okay the meeting the witch meeting joy  that's right I'm gonna tell you about  the hell's a charm some wine to go with  the cheese like that like there for  chance sorry this is in my mizzle this  is chisel whatever clamp it  this is Washington politics theme this  way this way  [Music]  [Music]